well joining me now to talk more about
cancer vaccines is andreas kaufman a
biologist and cancer researcher from
berlin's cherite hospital thank you very
much for being with us here on tomorrow
today
how close are we to seeing these
personalized vaccines against cancer on
a large scale
i believe that we are rather close to
seeing these vaccines being applied to
patients in clinical studies
and after the successful
results of these studies we will see
marketing of these vaccines all right
well as we saw in the film there is no
one size fits all vaccine how different
do these vaccines then have to be to
target the specific cancers
it depends on the cancer if it's a
spontaneous cancer like kidney cancer or
lung cancer then they have to be
individualized but for example in
cervical cancer where we know that human
papilloma viruses induce the
transformation the occurrence of the
cancer we can have vaccines that are
more
broadly
applicable all right why is it taking so
long to develop vaccines like these
actually we need to identify the
specific target structures
on the tumor cells
for individualized cancers they may be
very different from individual to
individual
and then we have to overcome
an
immune system inability
and we have learned a lot about this but
we are not there yet to really combat
every cancer all right we've been
talking about preventative measures so
far but what about people who already
have cancer what is being done what new
approaches are being developed to treat
these cancers yeah we have learned that
these tumors can suppress the immune
response quite
effectively
so we um
we need to find new ways of
counteracting this immune suppression
so the vaccines are more effective all
right now you mentioned cervical cancer
um you've been working on a vaccine for
cervical cancer what progress have you
made
well i've been working on therapeutic
vaccines
we do see they are immunogenic they
produce an immune response
but they have not been effective to
cure patients actually we now have the
prophylactic vaccines and i'm also
working in this field
to understand how the mechanism of these
prophylactic vaccines are okay now you
mentioned hpv the human papilloma virus
which causes cervical cancer now
theoretically
this can wipe out cancer if young women
receive it early enough
having said that would you say that
germany is carrying out an effective
vaccine program unfortunately not we
have vaccination coverage of 40
only
the u.s of 30 percent of young women
and girls
australia has 90 coverage why is it so
low here then
this depends on the
system how vaccination is applied we
don't have school-based programs we have
an opportunistic system where women who
want to get or girls who want to get
vaccinated have to go to the doctor
there is no school based program okay
all right andreas kaufman we're going to
leave it there but we thank you very
much for this discussion today